اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصده معكم ابرز
المستجدات في العناوين
حصيله ضحايا اشتباكات السودان في ارتفاع
ومحادثات جده تبحث عن هدنه دائمه ومسارات
انسانيه
روسيا
على كيا ومدن اوكرانيه وقوه فاغنر تستانف
معركه
ترحيب روسي وتحفظ امريكي على عوده سوريا
للجامعه العربيه واشنطن تشكك في رغبه
الاسد في الحل
في الامثال الاخيره لسباق الرئاسه التركيه
هاردوغان يوجه رساله لمعارضيه عبر الحشود
الضخمه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا تتعلق امال وقف القتال
في السودان ولو بصوره مؤقته على محادثات
جدا التي بدات امس الاحد بين ممثلين من
طرفي الصراع بينما شوهد السحب الدخان في
سماء البلاد جراء السيمبايل اشتباكاته
والقصف المتبادل بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع فعده المعارك لم تهدا مع
دخول الصرع الرابع لترفع حصله الضحايا من
قتلى وجرحى اخر ارقام مشاهدين تتحدثون عن
سقوط نحو 500 قتيل واكثر من 2500 اصابه
بحسب ما اعلنت عنه نقابه اطباء السودان
النقابه مشاهدينا اشارت ايضا الى ان هناك
العديد من الاصابات والوفيات غير مسموعه
في هذا الحصر لان الفرق الطبيه لم تتمكن
من الوصول الى المستشفيات في ظل صعوبه
التنقل بسبب الوضع الامني متابع
ومن ام درمان مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الصحفي
مقداد حسن اهلا بك مقداد وصفنا الوضع
الامني في العاصمه الخرطوم وفيوم درمان
ايضا هو اين تركزت الاشتباكات الاخيره بين
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
اهلا احمد نعم ربما يمكن ان نقول ان هذه
اللحظات تعتبر لحظات هادئه في مدينه
الخرطوم كانت قبلها اشتباكات سمع عدويه
وهنا في ام درمان صباح في هذا الصباح
الباكر وقبل قليل ايضا سمعنا كذلك تحليق
في الطائرات في سماء الخرطوم ربما هي تكون
لرصد تمركز قوات الدعم السريع في التي
تنتشر في مناطق مختلفه من العاصمه الخرطوم
اهمها القصر الجمهوري ومحيط القياده
العامه ووسط السوق العربي بالاضافه الى
مناطق مختلفه من مدينه بحري وكذلك في
الهيئه العامه للاذاعه والتلفزيون وجنوب
ووسط ام درمان
طائرات الاستطلاع يعني تحلق بصوره متواصله
بين لحظه واخرى وربما نحن نتحدث الان عن
تداعيات هذه الحرب والمفاوضات التي بدات
يوم السبت
ودخلت في الثانيه
بين الاطراف المتنازعه التي تقودها وساطه
امريكيه وسعوديه ربما الحديث الان يدور عن
هذه المفاوضات وماذا ستسفر عنه في الايام
القليل الماضيه والتي هي بالاساس تدعو لي
فتح ممرات انسانيه امنه لتامين كل
الاحتياجات التي يحتاجها المواطن من ماء
وغذاء وكهرباء وكذلك كل السلعه الضروريه
ويامل الوسط يعني امداد ذلك بوقف دائم
لاطلاق النار والذي تراه
الذي يراه الناطق الرسمي باسم الجيش انه
يقول ان هذه المفاوضات ربما تفضي فقط
لممرات انسانيه امنه ولا وجود لتفاوض ولا
سياسه في هذه النقطه بينما هنالك مواطن
ياملون ان ان تفضي لفتح مرات انسانيه امنه
تامل لهم حياتهم بشكل طبيعي وهناك الاخر
من ينصر او يدعم الجيش في حسم هذه المعركه
وهناك اخ تدعمون قوات الدعم السريع وهناك
من يدعمون وقف الحرب وانهاء هذه الحاله
التي استمرت للاسبوع الرابع هنا في
السودان ومن تداعياتها النزح الالاف الى
الولايات المجاوره والى الدول السودان
المجاوره منها مصر واثيوبيا وكذلك جنوب
السودان وشرقا الى تشاد الملايين ينزحون
الى تلك المناطق بحسب المتحده تتحدث عن ان
870 الفا يمكن ان تطالهم هذه الموجه هذا
ان تحدثنا عن الالاف الذين اصلا بالفعل
خرجوا عن طريق ميناء بورسودان ومحطه
وقاعده وادي السجن الجويه وكذلك شمالا
بمعمر بمعبر ارجين وبالتالي فان ذلك يدعو
الى ان يستتب الامن في السودان التي
يتداعيات هذه الحرب التي تدور الرابع
انما دعى الى انتشار الخرطور في بقيه
المدن العاصمه المثلث الان العاصمه هل
يمكن القول ان الحياه بدات تعود طبيعتها
في بعض المناطق في العاصمه المثلثه
نعم يمكن ان نقول انها بدات في مناطق
بعيده من الاشتباكات نسبيا او او او هي
يعني تعتبر تحت سيطره
يعني قوات الشعب المسلحه باعتبار انها
قريبه جدا من المناطق المسلحه وبالتالي
فاننا نتحدث عن ان ايضا المناطق التي توجد
فيها تمركزات الدعم السريع هناك مواطنون
يتحدثون عن انهم اصبحوا يتعايشون مع هذه
القوات لكن ايضا متخوفون من ان ترتد
الهجمات التي يمكن ان تحدث في اي لحظه
بينهم وبين القوات المسلحه ايضا هنالك
مناطق تعتبر لا تطالها هذه الاشتباكات
نتيجه لبعدها ربما قليلا من المواقع
السياديه والاستراتيجيه بدات فيها الحياه
تعود بصوره شبه طبيعيه لكن انقطاع كثير من
السلع الاستراتيجيه ينعكس سلبا على حياتهم
وبالتالي فاننا نقول ان الحياه
طبيعيه وهناك النسبه من الامن لكن هنالك
يعني توقف لدولاب العمل في تلك المناطق
وان كثير من المواطنين يواجهون امكانيه
انقطاع
مرتباتهم وانقطاع كذلك اموالهم التي
يستطيعون ان يؤمنوا بها قوتهم اليومي
خصوصا ونحن نتحدث عن عن قله الاموال التي
الان يعني داخل الميزان الصرفي للدوله
بهذا القدر شكرا لك مقداد حسن الصحافي كنت
معنا تحيه مقداد
اذا مشاهدينا بينما تبقى الانظار ترصد
الوضع في السودان تتجه الامال الى جده
التي انطلقت فيها امس محادثات تمهيديه غير
مباشره بين ممثلين من الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع وقد اعلنت الخارجيه
السعوديه في بيان ان هذه المباحثه تستمر
لايام حتى الوصول الى وقف فعال ودائم
لاطلاق النار الخارجيه السعوديه مشاهدينا
اكدت ايضا في بيانها ان السودان يمر بازمه
غير مسبوقه وان الخيار الوحيد هو الوقوف
الى جانبه
مشاهدينا من اوستن يضم الينا الاكاديمي
والبحث السياسيه السودانيه محمد عثمان
تقييمك لهذه المحادثات في جدها بين
الطرفين النزاع دعم السلعوه السوداني ومدى
فرصها في حل هذه او نزع الفتيل هذه الازمه
في السودان
تحياتي لك اخي الفاضل لقناتك الموقع
الواقع ان الطابع العام لهذه المفاوضات
شكليه وموضوعيه يوحي بانها غير جاده
من من
الممثلين من مستوى التمثيل ومن الموضوعات
المطروحه للنقاش نحن الان امام ازمه
انسانيه هذا امام حرب الدروس تدور في
العاصمه الخرطوم ويتحدثون عن جسد انسانيه
وفتح ممرات امنه ولا مجال للحديث عن اي
وضع سياسي او اي او وقف الاطلاق النار او
حتى اي تسويه سياسيه لهذا النزاع هذا لكن
يعني توافق الطرفين على هدنه انسانيه يمكن
ان افتح الباب امام توافق حول وقف الحرب
تماما في السودان
والشاهد يا عزيزي الفاضل ان النوايا اهم
من الهدن الواقع ان هنالك سبع هدى هشه
واخترقت جميعها لان ليست هنالك
نيه لدى الطرفين في حل هذا النزاع كلا
الطرفين للاسف الشديد الى الان يعتقد انه
يمكن ان يحسم هذا النزاع صفريا ونحن الان
ندخل في اسبوعنا الرابع وليست هنالك اي
مؤشرات لاي من الطرفين في قدرته على حل
هذا النزاع صفريا والانتصار على الطرف
الاخر
الان هذا الملف مؤشرات تطور هذا الملف
اقراها من واشنطن وليس من الخرطوم
بعد صراع طوال الاربع سنوات في التعاطي مع
الشام السوداني من انه ملف سياسي او انه
ملف امني وضح جليا ان الملف الامني انتصر
في التعاطي مع شان السوداني وتداعيات هذا
الانتصار وضح جليا من خلال لجنه القوات
المسلحه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكيز قدمت رؤيه تشاؤميه جدا عن الوضع
في السودان تبيعها جف صولفان مستشار الامن
القومي الذي تحدث ان الصراع الدائر في
السودان الان هو تهديد للامن القومي
الامريكي وتلا ذلك قطاع سياسي من وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
هو يعني يعني لسوء الحظ التزامن التزامن
الازمه السودانيه الحاليه الان جاء في
المرتبه الثالثه بالنسبه لاولويات السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه نحن عندنا ازمه قرانيه
هي الازمه رقم واحد بالنسبه لامريكا الان
ظهرت ازمه جديده في تايوان وفي ازمه
اقتصاديه داخليه ازمه الدين العام الان
داخل امريكا بالتوازي مع كل هذه الان نحن
ندخل لسنه ابتعد انتخابات سنه مفصليه في
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه فاي تعاطي مع
اي شانه بيكون عنده مردوده الانتخابي لاي
من الحزبين صحيح الامان الامريكان نظروا
الى خطوره الوضع الامني الان في السودان
السودان الان يمثل خطر يهدد كل المنطقه
لاجل هذا هم يزعمون الا لا يتمدد هذا
الصراع ان لا يتحول الى حرب اهليه ومن ثم
ان لا ينتقل الى اي من دول الجوار الهشه
انت يعني تعي اهميه الاهميه جيوستراليه
للسودان محاط بالسبعه دول كلها عندها
اعتذر منك سيد شفيع هذا ما سمح به الوقت
ربما نكمل معك في سياق لقاء اخر من
اوستوتا مع الاكاديميه والبحث السياسيه
السودانيه الشافي محمد عثمان تحياتي
مشاهدينا مع استماع الاشتباكات بين قوات
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريه تستمر
عمليات اجلاء مواطن مختلف الدول من
السودان وفي اليمن وصلت اولى طائرات
الاجلاء التي تحمل على متنها 180 مواطنا
يمنيا كانوا عالقين في السودان حيث وصلت
الطائره الى مطار عدم مطار جده وذلك بعد
قيام المملكه السعوديه باجلاء مواطني
مختلف الدول عبر البحر من مدينه بورسودان
القريبه من مدينه جده هذا ويستمر وصول
المواطنين اليمنيين بطائره اخرى تقل نحو
250 راكبا
عند الهروب من الحرب ونيرانها قد لا تهم
الوسيله الفارون من معارك السودان وتحديد
من منطقه جودا الشماليه الى معبر المنطقه
الجنوبي لم يجدو سوى عربه الكارو وهي
وسيله تقليديه بدات تنشط عند معبر جوده في
ظل الاشتباكات الاخيره
وسيله نقل تقليديه برز نشاطها لنقل
الفارين من الاشتباكات السودانيه من منطقه
جودا الشمالي الى داخل الحدود الجنوب
السودانيه ابرم معبر جودا الجنوبي وهي
وسيله بديله للسيارات التي توقفت حركتها
نسبه لشح الوقود
يعني بنجيب الرقم من هنا يعني كل عشر
دقيقه احيانا مواصلات ما عندنا هنا
في النهايه وصلت انا شعور غريب هكذا قالت
حق الروس وليم التي استقلت الكارو لاول
مره
كوسيله نقل محليه قائله ان ظروف الحرب قد
تجبرك على استخدام اي وسيله لتصل بسلام
الى وجهتك
مشيره الى ان للحرب ظروفها وللضروره احكام
غريب جدا جدا
قطه الناس يمكن يضحكوا
الدنيا كده خلانا مجبورين نركب الكارو ده
وكده
النساء والاطفال هم اكثر الفئات التي
تستخدم هذه الوسيله وهي وسيله بطيئه لكنها
سحله الحركه اذ تبلغ قيمه تذكرتها بين
الجودتين نحو الفي جناح سوداني يعني حسب
حسب الظرف مننا عندهم عنده الفدان
الله سهله الامور
احنا حابين نساعدهم اكثر قصص وحكايه
ووسائل ستبقى صوره عالقه في افحان
الكثيرين خاصه الذين فره من المناطق
الساخنه الى مناطق امنه
مبيور شيرلو العربيه مابر جودا الجنوبي
نشاطنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل القوات
الاسرائيليه تشن حمله اعتقالات واسعه ضد
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في اوكرانيا
افادت مصادر العربيه بان روسيا شنت حمله
غارات واسعه على عديد من المدن الاوكرانيه
عشيه احتفالات يوم النصر في التاسع من
مايو ووقعت انفجارات عنيفه وقويه غرب
العاصمه
المطله على البحر الاسود وايضا
من جهه اخرى قال الجيش الاوكراني انه تصدى
لهجوم للمسيرات غرباء وحذر من غارات جويه
كما دوا الصفاره الانذار في مناطق مقاطعه
التي لا تزال تسيطر عليها
اشخاص على الاقل اصيبوا في ضربات روسيه
على المدينه
[موسيقى]
وعلى ضوء الحديث عن هجوم مضاد تاخر وبين
عزم ورغبه في الصمود من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني قالت الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
قواتها دمرت 35 طائره الايرانيه الصنع
التي اطلقتها روسيا على اهداف مختلفه في
انحاء البلاد خلال الساعه الماضيه واضافت
بان الجيش الروسي نفذ سته عشر هجوما
صاروخيا على العديد من المدن الاوكرانيه
تحديدا خاركيف وخيرسون
وشارت الى ان الجيش الروسيه نفذ 61 غاره
جويه واثنين وخمسين هجوما بواسطه انظمه
اطلاق الصواريخ الثقيله على مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيه ومناطق ماهوله بالسكان خلال
الساعه الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه
[موسيقى]
في اوكرانيا من الجيش الروسي
نعم يعني الان في هذا الاسنان تدوس سفارات
الانذار في سبع مقاطعات شرقيه في شرق
اوكرانيا
او مسيرات ستطلق على تلك المناطق لانه قبل
حوالي عشر دقائق دوره سفارات في تلك
المناطق ولا ننسى بالامس يعني ما حصل ليله
امس في هذه المنطقه التي انا متواجد بها
الثاني الثاني عشر والنصف وبدات روسيا
باطلاق مسيرات ايرانيه الصنع من نوع شهيد
باتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف فصدت لها
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه يعني اكثر من
30 مسيره تم اسقاطها في سماء مقاطعه وسمعه
والعاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف حطام احدى
المسيرات سقط على احد المباني السكنيه في
منطقه سلومس ادى الى اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص
وايضا حطام اخر سقط فيه منطقه
مما ادى ايضا الى
سقوط يعني شريحين وفي مطار جوليانا احد
احدى المسيرات على احد المدارس دون ان
يسبب باضرار كبيره ايضا في مقاطعات اخرى
مقاطعه اوديس ستعرضت لضربات صاروخيه ليله
امس احد الصواريخ اصابه يعني مخزن للمواد
الغذائيه من ما ادى الى اشتعاله ونشب حريق
كبير عملت فرق الاطفاء والدفاع المدني على
اطفاء الحريق على مدرسه ساعتين او ثلاثه
ساعات في تلك المنطقه خرسون ايضا سمع
اصوات انفجارات عنيفه بعد استهدافها
بصواريخ اس 3 مئه تشير وايضا تم استهدافها
مدينه شرني تم اسقاط مسيرتين ومنطقه ايضا
تم اسقاط ثلاثه مسيرته حصيله المسيرات
التي تم اطلاق ها خمسه وثلاثين مسيره
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه استطاعت اسقاط
جميع المسيرات دون ان تسبب باضرار كبيره
خاصه ان العاصمه الاوكرانيه هي المره
الاولى التي يتم اطلاق مسيرك بهذا العدد
الكبير وفي وقت محدود لا يتجاوز السنه نعم
شكرا محمد وسنبقى معك في متابعه دائما
لتطورات جديده في هذا الملف من كيا كنت
معنا الصحفي محمد البابا شكرا
[موسيقى]
في جبهه بخمه مشاهدينا اعلن قائد
استئناف الهجوم على المدينه هو ان قواته
تواصل التقدم حيث لم يتبقى سوى كيلو مترين
مربعين تقريبا من المدينه تحت سيطره
القوات الاوكرانيه مراسل العربيه نقل ايضا
عن مصادر مطلع قولها كان صعبا للغايه في
الاحياء الغربيه من المدينه لكن القوات
الاوكرانيه دافعت بكل قوتها فاجنر تحاول
في هذا السياق السيطره من الناحيه
الشماليه الغربيه
والدخول الى جهه الغرب من المحور الشمالي
اعان المسؤول المحلي عن منطقه زابوريجيا
والمعين من روسيا يفكيني باليتسكي عن
اجلال اكثر من 1600 شخص بينهم
660 طفلا من المناطق القريبه من محطه
عن عبر تطبيق تيليجرام انه تم وضع الاشخاص
الذين تم اجلائهم في مركز الاقامه المؤقته
المخصص لسكان مناطق خط المواجهه في منطقه
زابوريجيا في مديانسك جنوب شرقي اوكرانيا
قال مصدر مطلع الى الولايات المتحده لديها
ثقه كبيره في دقه ادعاء اوكرانيا بانها
استخدمت نظام الدفاع الامريكي باتريوت
لاعتراض صاروخ
تفوق صاروخ روسي اذا تفوق سرعته سرعه
الصوت واضاف المصدر ان ادعاء اوكرانيا
اعتراضها لصاروخ الروسي اثار ضجه داخل
الفينتاجون في اوكرى في اواخر الاسبوع
الماضي مشيرا الى انها مهمه لعده اسباب
مشاهدينا منك اوراق رمضان رئيس مركز
الاوراس الدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك
سيدي رمضان معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه
خارطه الهجمات الروسيه على مناطق مختلفه
في في اوكرانيا ليله امس ما الذي تشيي به
وهل لها علاقه بشكل او باخر باحتفالات يوم
النصر غدا
طبعا هناك عده يعني عوامل مرتبطه ومتشابكه
اولا هناك رمزيه بخصوص يعني اقتراب او
يبقى يوم من عيد النصر تريد ان تبين انها
ستنتصر على النظريه الجديده في اوكرانيا
حسب القاموس الروسي الذي نسمعه عبر
وكذلك هناك امور يعني تكتيكيه استراتيجيه
عندما تستخدم يعني المسيرات وخمسه وثلاثون
مسيره كلها اتت الى اقليم العاصمه
والعاصمه اظن ان هذه المساله هي مساله
لمعرفه تموقع وتواجد المضادات
والدفاعات الجويه وخاصه الروس انهم الان
يريدون الحصول على معلومات في مكان تواجد
الباتل المنظومه التي حسب ما عرفنا انها
تمكنت من اسقاط يعني الصاروخ
الكنجال وهو بسرعه فرط الصوت
واريد ان اعقب بخصوص يعني ان الامريكان
يعني لديهم ثقه المساله ان منظومه يجب ان
يكون هناك مسؤول ومراقب وكذلك مستشار فني
امريكي من البانطاغون يراقب ويساعد ويعني
هذه المرحله يعني مهمه ولذلك انا انظر الى
تصريحات انها عفويه شعبويه لان الامريكان
يعرفون كل شيء كيف تعمل وما هي الصواريخ
وما هي الاهداف التي تعارضها وتضمنها في
المفاجاه لناحيه انه ان هذه المنظومه نجحت
في اسقاط صاروخ
فرط صوتي
روسيا ربما بالنسبه
نعم الامريكان يعرفون يعني بكل شيء لديهم
كل المعلومات لانه هم الذين يديرون هذه
المنظومه وهي مرتبطه بشبكه الاقمار
الصناعيه وكذلك الطائرات وكل المنظومه
الرقمانيه وهم يعرفون كل شيء بخصوص
الامريكان يعني هذا واضح من المعلومه لك ي
يعني نحترم المشاهد الكريم
بهذا القدر كنت معنا اوراق رمضان رئيس
مركز الاوراس الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
تحياتي شكرا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدين اعتقال الجيش الاسرائيلي 15
فلسطينيين الليله الماضيه من مختلف انحاء
الضفه الغربيه والقدس جاء ذلك خلال حمله
مداهمه لعده مناطق تخللها بل تخللتها
مواجهات بين الفلسطينيين والقوات
الاسرائيليه الاشتباكات مشاهدينا امتدت
الى مدينه نابلس هو بلده برقين شمال اراضي
فلسطينيه هذا وشيع الالاف من اهالي قريه
صندالا جثمان الشاب ديار العمري الذي قتل
على يد مستوطن اسرائيلي
نشاطنا مستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
الصين تحذر واشنطن من نهج التصعيد في قضيه
تايوان
[موسيقى]
حاصله ضحايا اشتباكات السودان في ارتفاع
ومحادثات جده تبحث عنه هدنه دائمه ومسارات
انسانيه
روسيا تشن حمله غارات واسعه على كييف ومدن
اوكرانيا وقوه فيغنير تستانف معركه بخموت
ترحيب وتحفظ امريكي على عوده سوريا
للجامعه العربيه واشنطن تشكك في رغبه
الاسد في الحل
في الامثال الاخيره لسباق الرئاسه التركيه
اردوغان يوجه رساله لمعارضيه عبر الحشود
الضخمه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد رحب مجلس سوريا
الديمقراطيه بما وصفه بالتحرك الدولي
بخصوص القضيه السوريه بما في ذلك اجتماع
مجلس جامعه الدول العربيه وعبر المجلس عن
امله في ان تساهم المبادره العربيه في
تهيئه الظروف المناسبه لعوده امنه للاجئين
وقال انه مستعد للتعاون في هذا الشان
واضاف مجلس الديمقراطي انا ان على الخطوات
الدوريه والعربيه ان تراعي ماساه السوريين
التي لا يمكن ان تنتهي دون عمليه سياسيه
متكامله تشارك فيها جميع الاطراف دون
اقصاء على حد وصفه ودع المجلس المعارضه
لعقد مؤتمر وطني لاجل مصلحه الوطنيه وابدا
استعداده لدعم العمليه السياسيه لانهاء
الازمه السوريه
وفي ردود الفعل الدولي على عوده سوريا
للجامعه العربيه مبادرت روسيا باعداد
ترحيبها وقالت ان قرار عوده سوريا الى
الحضن العربي سيسهم في تحسين الاجواء في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط
الترحيب الروسي مشاهدينا قابله تحفظ
امريكي حيث اعلنت الخارجيه الامريكيه انها
تتفهم سعي الشركاء للتواصل المباشر مع
الرئيس السوري بشر الاسد لمزيد من الضغط
لحل الازمه السوريه وقالت الخارجيه
الامريكيه في بيان انها تشكك في رغبه بشار
الاسد بحد الازمه في سوريا لكنها تتفق مع
الشركاء العرب حول الاهداف النهائيه مشيره
الى ان عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه قد
تكون مبكره
فعوده سوريا هي بدايه للطريق وليس نهايه
للمسار بهذه الكلمات لخص امينو عام جامعه
الدول العربيه اهم قرارات مجلس الوزراء
الخارجيه العرب الذي اجتمع لمناقشه ملفات
سوريا والسودان وفلسطين وخلص الى تشكيل
لجنتي اتصال تضمان الجامعه والرياض
والقاهره لمواصله حلحله الامور
مصر بصفتها رئيس الجلسه اشارت الى مسؤوليه
الجميع عن تقدم المسار السوري في اطار
شروط وضعت في كل من جده وعمان تتعلق
بالعوده الامنه للاجئين وخطر الارهاب وضبط
الحدود لمنع تهريب المخدرات وغيرها ضروره
التفاعل الايجابي مع كل المكونات سواء
كانت سياسيه او انسانيه
وقضايا اخرى
ذات تاثير على المحيط الاقليمي وقضيه
تواجد القوات الاجنبيه دول مؤيده لقرار
عوده سوريا ابد ت رضاها وان كان الجميع
يعلم انه مسار ليس بالسهل يجب ان نكون
واقعين مساله سوريه مساله معقده صحيح
مساله الى علاقه بالسياده السوريه وداخل
السوري ولكن
في الساحه السوريه الان هناك
دول مختلفه
مصالحها متداخله ومؤثره ايضا في ساحه
السوريه ليس
بقرار
لاقامه علاقات طبيعيه بين الدول العربيه
وسوريا هذا قرار سيادي لكل دوله على حده
السودان خرج بما جاء من اجله لناحيه تاكيد
وزراء الخارجيه على سيادته ووحده اراضيه
والتعامل مع الازمه الحاليه باعتبارها
شانا داخليا نسمي القرارات التي اصدارها
الميس الوزاري جامعه الدول العربيه اليوم
حيث اكدت على سياده السودان ووحدته وسلامه
اراضيه
وعدم التدخل في شؤون الداخليه عدد سوريا
الى الحاضنه العربيه مره اخرى وسواء كانت
ستسجل حضورا في قمه الرياض القادمه من
عدمه فان الامر الان منوط بدمشق كي تحقق
شروط التي وضعتها لها الدول العربيه
لتاثير قرار العوده تامر نصرت العربيه
القاهره
قبل اسبوع واحد من الانتخابات الحاسمه في
تركيا استطاع الرئيس رجب اردوغان حشد
عشرات الالاف في اسطنبول باكبر انتخابيه
تشابه البلاد وذلك بعد يوم واحد فقط من
تجمع المعارضه الكبير في اسطنبول ايضا حيث
يسعى كل المرشحين لاغناع الفئه المتردده
بالتصويت لهما
[موسيقى]
سير على الاقدام او في حافلات او
بسياراتهم الخاصه مئات الالاف من سكان
اسطنبول والولايات المجاوره استجابوا
لدعوه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان للحضور الى
مطار اتاتورك والمشاركه في اكبر تجمع
انتخابي تشهده البلاد
عشرات الالاف حضروا تجمع اردوغان الذي
اراد توجيه عده رسائل للمعارضه ومنها انه
ما زال يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره في الشارع
خصوصا في اكبر مدن البلاد اسطنبول نحن
نحب وسندعمه يوم الاحد القادم وسيظهر
للعالم كله ولترى ميرال اكشنار وكليتشار
اوغلو هذه الحشود
اقرار تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان ولما حدث في
الفتره الاخيره من تقدم سننتخبه ونحن مع
تحالف الشعب وسندعمه
نحن هنا لندعم رئيسنا مقابل تحالف الامه
الذين حبسوا اربكان واسقطوا الحكومه في
الماضي
اردوغان لم يفوت فرصه الاشاره الى تسجيلات
تخص منافسه كمالك الجدار اوغلو زعيم
المعارضه ومرشح الطاوله السداسيه للرئاسه
حيث يتهم الرئيس خصمه بانه نسق مع حزب
العمال الكردستاني وتنظيم جولن وقوى غربيه
في سبيل وصوله للرئاسه
امريكا
بنزين
سيد كمال هيا اعلن عن الاشخاص الذين
التقيت معهم في محطه الوقود وفي المطعم
خلال زيارتك الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
قبل اسبوع واحد فقط من الانتخابات الحاسمه
ما زالت هناك فئه متردده ويامل اردوغان في
كسب اصواتها من خلالها كذا حشود
في الانتخابات هذا العدد من الحشود اذا
اردنا مقارنتها مع تجمعات المعارضه فانها
لا تصل الى مستوى تجمعات رئيس الجمهوريه
وهذا سينعكس على صناديق الاقتراع
الائتلاف الحاكم بقياده حزب العداله
والتنميه الذي خسر مدينه اسطنبول في اخر
انتخابات محليه اراد اظهار قوته في هذه
المدينه على وجه التحديد بعد يوم واحد فقط
من اكبر تجمع للمعارضه في نفس المدينه
لكنه لم يكن بحجم التجمع الانتخابي
للائتلاف الحاكم في استمرار لحرب الساحات
والميادين بين المعسكرين
وستغري هذه الحشود الناخبين المترددين
بالتصويت له
زيدان زنجلو العربيه
في وقت تحتدم المنافسه بين المرشحين
وانصارهم في تركيا تعرض رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول المعارض اكرم امام اوغلو لرشق
بالحجاره في ولايه اردوروم اثناء كلمه
الله بين انصاره غادر بعدها التجمع
الانتخابيه دون ان يكمل خطابه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من اسطنبول مشاهدينا ينضموا الينا المحلل
هذه الكبيره التي نجح
دوجانوها هل ستكون بمثابه بطاقه العبور
التي تؤمن له الفوز في الانتخابات المقبله
ام ان المهمه ربما تبدو اصعب من ذلك بكثير
تحيه لك لمشاهدينا الكرام طبعا المنافسه
قويه في هذه المرحله لكن بصراحه في
الانتخابات
المحليه الاخيره كان هناك فارق صغير بين
المعارضه والحكومه لكن راينا عندما اعادوا
الانتخابات قريب من مليون صوت كان في
المعارضه فازت في تلك المره الان طبعا هم
جمعوا لا زالت شعبيته موجوده لا ننكر ذلك
لكن جمعوا من الاطراف من المدن الاخرى ومن
نفس مدينه اسطنبول هؤلاء يخافون من
الخساره وياتون بهذه الحشود الكبيره لكن
بصراحه يعني المنافسه قويه
ولا يثقون ولا يقدرون ابدا ان يصلون الى
51 بالمئه في الجوله الاولى حتى
يصلون الى الحكم مره اخرى طيب لكن يبدو
حتى الان انه اردوغان يعول على ما يبدو
على ملف الاكراد وعلى ملف فتح الله جولن
وايضا العام الاتهامات بالعماله الغرب
للنيل من خصومه السياسيين هل يبدو ذلك
الجدوى هل هي نقاط سالبه حقيقيه او نقاط
ضعف حقيقيه في سجلات منافسه
طبعا هناك اتهامات متبادله بين الجانبين
الان الساحه ساخنه جدا بتمام المعنى الان
مثلا اتهامات الرئيس اردوغان بالنسبه الى
المعارضه موجوده ان هؤلاء يريدون يقتربون
من الدول الغربيه وغير ذلك من جهه اخرى
المعارضه تتهمهم بالفساد المالي هناك
فيديوهات نشرت بشكل قوي جدا في الاسبوع
الاخير طبعا راينا كما كان في تقريركم انه
هجوم كان على اكرم
الدعايه للمعارضه بالنتيجه هؤلاء غضبانين
اتباع الحكومه الان غضبانين بانهم يخافون
من الخساره ومن تراجع شعبيه حزبهم نعم طيب
هناك ايضا متابعين تسالون يعني عما يمكن
ان تقدمه المعارضه الان
لربما لرفع مستوى حظوظها ايضا بعيدا عن
الحديث عن اخطاء اردوغان في خلال عقدين
الماضيين والتي تبدو معروفه لدى الاتراك
ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه المعارضه لرفع
مستوى حضورها
طبعا الشعب يريدون يعني وجود جديده في
السياسه التركيه نفس شديد واراده التغيير
لا زالت موجوده لكن المعارضه كانت فاشله
بصراحه لحد الان لكن بشكل او اخر بالنتيجه
صار استقطاب في تركيا يعني قسم من
المواطنين اتباع قويه اردوغان مهما يكون
الامر وهناك قسم اخر يريدون ان يتخلصون من
هذه الحكومه باي شكل من الاشكال الان
المعارضه تريد ان تقدم برامج اقتصاديه
شخصيات اقتصاديه قويه يقولون نحن سوف نعين
الميزان هو الاهليه في تعيين الاشخاص وغير
ذلك التقارب مع دول الغربيه عدم التداخل
في التدخل في شؤون الدول العربيه والجيران
تطبيع العلاقات مع سوريا عوده اللاجئين
هناك كثير من الملفات بيد المعارضه ايضا
يقدمونه للشعب التركي لنرى النتيجه في
الاسبوع القادم وهي ملفات بالتاكيد يعني
يطرب بسماعها جزء كبير من الشعب التركي
ماذا عن الجيل الشباب هذا الجيل الذي يمكن
ان يكون له الحسم او القدره على تغيير
موازين القوى بين الطرفين في هذه
الانتخابات
طبعا ست ملايين من الشباب اول مره سوف
يصابطون في هذه الانتخابات ونحن نعرف من
استطلاعات الراي انه قريب من 90 بالمئه
يرفضون حكم اردوغان
فيؤيدون المعارضه بشكل عام هؤلاء كبروا مع
هذه الحكومه عقدين هذا الامر عادي جدا
الجيل الجديد والحكومه ايضا تعرف انه جيل
الجديد يريدون يصوتون يعني 90 بالمئه
واكثر لصالح المعارضه هذه من مشاكل
الحكومه الحاليه واحد اسباب تراجع شعبيته
مولانا طيب في تقديرك يعني اي طرفين الان
هو الاقدر على استماله الاغلبيه الصامته
من الشعب التركي حتى الان
الاغلبيه بصراحه بفارق قليل مع المعارضه
حاليا لانه يعني المدن الشرقيه والجنوبيه
التحقوا الى المعارضه خاصه دعم حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطيه
التضخم الاسعار جعل الحياديين في طرف
المعارضه بصراحه يعني هؤلاء كانوا كثير من
المؤيدين للرئيس اردوغان تراجعوا عن
تاييدهم بسبب تضخم فلا يوجد برنامج جديد
الاقتصادي لحكومه الرئيس اردوغان ليقدمون
للشعب التركي ولهذا السبب كثير من هؤلاء
الوسطين الان في طرف المعارضه ممكن ان
نقول ذلك من الصبور اذا كنت مع المحلل
السياسي جواد جوكا شكرا السيد جواد على كل
ما تفضلت به
[موسيقى]
دعا وزير خري يصل الى ضروره تحقيق
الاستخاره في العلاقات الصينيه الامريكيه
لتفادي دوامه التصعيد بين البلدين وفي
اجتماع مع السفير الامريكي لدى الصين في
بكين حتى المسؤول الصيني واشنطن على تصحيح
تصوراتها عن بلاده والعوده الى ما اسماه
بالعقلانيه داعيا الى التوقف عن الاستمرار
في تفريغ مبدا الصين الواحده فيما يتعلق
بقضيه تايوان
قضى وزير خارجيه باكستاني
ونظيره الافغاني امير خان التقي عقد
اتفاقا للتعزيز التجاره وخفض التوتر على
طول الحدود بين البلدين ورغم استمرار
هجمات المسلحين ضد قوات الامن فان الاتفاق
يهدف الى تحسين التجاره الثنائيه ومكافحه
الارهاب كما قام الوزيران بمحادثات مع
وزير خارجيه صيني من اجل تعزيز العلاقات
بين باكستان وافغانستان والصين بعد تعليق
الحوار بينهم لسنوات طويله
كشف تقرير صادر عن صحيفه تايمز البريطانيه
بان ايران طرحت مواقع تراثيه للبيع وذلك
بهدف تخفيض ديونها في مواجهه العقوبات
المفروضه عليها حيث تم عرض بعض اقدم كنوز
ايران التاريخيه في مزاد على الانترنت
لخفض ديون الدوله في مواجهه العقوبات
المشدده ومن المتوقع طرح 19 موقعا للبيع
في 22 مما يلي من قبل وزاره التراث
الثقافي والسياحه والصناعات اليدويه
مشاهدينا دعى تقرير الحكومي فرنسي الى
تغيير جذري في استهلاك المياه في فرنسا
لتجنبك كوارث نقص مياه الشرب في السنوات
القادمه واشار المشرفون على التقرير
المشترك بين الوزارات الفرنسيه المعنيه
الى انه تم تجنب الاسوا اثناء اداره جفاف
عام 2022 لكنه بالمقابل حذر من صعوبه
مواجهه مثل هذه الظروف اذا تكررت في
السنوات المقبله قد يبدو ان توفر مياه
لكن ليس بعد الان فمع استمرار ازمه الجفاف
الناجمه عن شرح الامطار خلال فصل الشتاء
في فرنسا اصبح مستقبل توفر المياه الصالحه
للشرب في السنوات المقبله من التحديات
الكبيره التي تواجهها السلطات الفرنسيه
ازمه الجفاف نتيجه نقص مياه الامطار في
فرنسا بدات تاخذ منحا اكثر خطوره فمستقبل
توفر مياه الشرب في السنوات القادمه بات
على المحك ولداري مخاطر عدم القدره على
تامين الامدادات دع تقرير حكومي فرنسي الى
تغيير جذريا في الاستهلاك لتجنب كوارث نقص
مياه الشرب في السنوات المقبله سنعاني في
2050 الى 40% من الاشخاص على سطح الارض
سوف يعانون من ازمه المياه ستكون ايضا
ازمه المياه للاسف هي مصدر النزاعات
والخلافات وهجره مناخيه كبيره داخليه او
خارجيه وبالتالي يتم العمل اليوم في فرنسا
على التوعيه بموضوع المياه خصوص ا المياه
الصالحه للشرب يلاحظ الفرنسيون هذا التغير
المناخي بشكل واضح هنا في سوق المزروعات
مثلا يحاول توما البحث عن نباتات تعيش
لمده اطول بعدما خسر ما خسره من نباتات في
حديقه منزله بسبب الجفاف
تعاني النباتات كثيرا في الوقت الحالي
فتغير مناخ الفصول يسبب عواقب وقيمه عليها
ما يجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه من حيث الجفاف
لكن اكثر ما يشغل تفكير زوجته ماري هو خطر
نقص مياه الشرب في المستقبل
40 نحاول توفير اكبر قدر من الماء نستحم
باعتدال ونكون حذرين في سهله وفي تطور اخر
مرتبط بهذا الجفاف اندلع حريق هائل جنوب
فرنسا قضى على نحو 930 هكتارا من الغابات
ليتسبب باضرار كبيره في تلك المنطقه رغم
نجاح السلطات في اخماد النيران زناعه
العربيه باريس
حرائق غير مسبوقه في البرتا في كندا ادت
الى اجلاء نحو 30 الف شخص من سكان
المقاطعه فيما اعلنت رئيسه الوزراء حاله
الطوارئ
[تصفيق]
وقبل الختام مشاهدينا ان عدوان
حصيره ضحايا اشتباكات السودان في ارتفاع
ومحادثات جده تبحث عن هدنه دائمه ومسارات
الانسانيه
روسيا تشن حمله غارات واسعه على كييفو مدن
اوكرانيه وقوه فاغمر تستانف معركه
ترحيب روسي وتحفظ امريكي على عده سوريا
للجامعه العربيه وهو واشنطن تشكك في رغبه
الاسد في الحل
في الامثال الاخيره لسباق الرئاسه التركيه
اردوغان يوجه رساله لمعارضيه عبر الحشود
الضخمه
نهايه هذه المشاهدين كونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات